mort de notre histoire
ils sont au
moins
aussi
dans les tons bien tapaï on y jouera
peut-être notre grand
sourire carnassier où tu parle ici mais
la promotion du vélo
on
essaie de faire saint cyr pour avoir un
métier où je pouvais être au contact des
hommes pouvoir former des hommes et
pouvoir avoir des responsabilités en
tant que femme est aussi un métier un
métier dynamique qui bouge est un métier
qui change qui changent souvent
psychologiquement c'était dur
physiquement ce n'était pas trop dur on
est parvenu tellement abîmée n'aurait
plus qu'à les justes avec 3 kilos en
moins
oh
[Musique]
en fait l'armée c'est sain c'est assez
simple défendre son pays s'entraîner
s'entraîner à servir les armes à servir
sous les armes c'est très simple
comme comme idée je veux dire pas comme
comme comme technique après comme
enseignement c on se rend compte
d'ailleurs que c'est difficile de dire
quand on regarde les films de guerre à
la télé on voit très bien que on croit
que la guerre est très facile et quand
on quand on rentre à couettes et qu'on
commence à apprendre les premiers le ba
ba du combat on se rend compte que
finalement faire la guerre c'est pas
évident l'école spéciale militaire de
saint-cyr
fondée en 1802 par bonaparte
[Applaudissements]
alors
ils s'instruisent pour vaincre la devise
de choc pour la future élite des
officiers de l'armée de terre
[Musique]
ici chacun vit dans la mythologie de ses
héros des exemples sur la ligne bleue de
leurs espérances
personnellement j'aime beaucoup le
capitaine stéphane déjà donné son nom à
une promotion il ya quelques années 80
et c'est également résistantes comme on
a un mec qui
dans les alpes et en fait c'est une
personnalité pleine de jeunesse de le
panache avec un côté un peu rebelle que
les élèves dont on peut on affectionne
particulièrement
ce côté rebelle vous pourrez enfin c'est
c'est une rébellion bien compris ça
c'est toujours la discipline mais il ya
un petit rien d'insolence fait pour nous
c'est ce qu'on appelle le panache et qui
fait quand on arrive à faire des choses
grandioses tout en
donnant l'impression en fait que
que c'est naturel qu'on fait qu'avec
beaucoup de plaisir et qu'on aime ça
bataillon non
à droite
[Musique]
pourquoi avez vous décidé vous d'être
militaire
parce que j'ai envie de voir du pays de
bouger de servir mon pays et puis de
commander des hommes
commandés dès que vous avez commandé
dans une entreprise ah oui je pense que
on peut imaginer comment naît dans une
entreprise les relations ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes puisque les
militaires sont 24 heures sur 24 avec
lorient il ya des relations peut-être
plus forte ce qui est en train de scier
saison
on
les sections sabres bien astiqués vos
sabres éviter le panachage de tenue donc
d'ailleurs c'est même interdit donc
gants blancs pour tout le monde
[Musique]
mais au delà des parades sacyr et
surtout une grande école trois ans
d'études scientifiques économiques ou
littéraires les filles 7 sur 170 dans le
2ème bataillon était admise jusqu'à
présent sont côte à côte a supprimé
cette année
mais c'est en deux
ça
pour elle le même régime que les garçons
une heure de sport par jour plus ce
jeudi après-midi
une préparation à une épreuve redoutée
par tous
le stage commando de guyane
[Musique]
nous les accompagnons la barre dans le
qg de la légion étrangère
le camp schulz on veut ici
au coeur de la pointe de femmes stand de
l'élite du 3e régiment étranger
d'infanterie
vous êtes venus pour l'action
et donc je vous promet de l'action
je vous promets de la sueur peut-être
les larmes mais vous allez pendant 12
jours
oublier tous vos soucis qui vous avez
dans la tête une seule devise je vaux ce
que je veux
et il est tant besoin d'être à l'aise il
suffit d'avoir du mat
et quand il ya des parcours collectif
des activités collectives il suffit
d'avoir de la cohésion donc je suis
résidente quelqu'un je serai votre
instructeur durant les deux jours qui va
durer ce stage mon adjoint le caporal ce
trek ont mené un coup de main alors vous
allez faire un stage d'aguerrissement
en résumé un stage d'aguerrissement
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un stage où la feront pas à grand
chose on a ramassé par la gueule pour
paris
donc qu'est ce que j'attends de vous
premièrement beaucoup de force morale
deuxièmement un peu de muscle quand même
hein et un tout petit petit poussière
d'intelligence vous allez voir si vous
avez tout ça ça va se passer très très
bien
benzema lui
jeudi enfin histoire pour les peaux ou
google et à terme non seulement après
ces propos
la détresse queen opposition pour les
porter
premier ressort le plasmodium falciparum
celui là c'est le plus dur vous pouvez
en trouver
attention à ça le paludisme vous pouvez
en crever nous sommes avec la 3e section
de la 5e compagnie même six élèves
officiers une seule fille stéphanie même
des hommes le deuxième mandat le
plasmodium vivax
celui-là est moins virulent moins
dangereux mais vous risquez de le garder
une dizaine d'années
à l'origine à condat c'est pas des
serpents venimeux d'anaconda sont des
serpents sont pas venimeux sont donc à
gif à gif ça veut dire y est reproché
c'est le plus grand serpent du monde à
cela naturellement ça peut aller jusqu'à
la taille moyenne 8 m le plus grand est
close au new york il mesure 10 mètres et
non à 10 mètres et 200 kg ils n'ont pour
la plupart jamais quitté l'europe mais
la première matinée ici leur donne un
avant goût d'une des régions les plus
inhospitalières de la planète
ils sont encadrés par l'adjudant cuenca
un amoureux des serpents 15 ans de
légion
côté pratique le caporal str à la
cassure à croate qui a combattu dans
l'ex yougoslavie avant de s'engager dans
la légion il ya trois ans
ok voilà une à la combat
et les jolies l'emploi énervé parce
qu'elle a mangé après l'autre ok mais
non comment on va la faire ce qu'on va
l'attraper
on va les rattraper par derrière ok
ok on va se mettre et bien derrière sa
tête
voilà on va le faire rattraper derrière
sa tête comme ça derrière le coup on
n'avance pas avec deux doigts ok on va
pas le penser avec des doigts parce que
ça va faire mal au ciel pas et ensuite
on attrape à peu près au milieu de corps
ok
vas-y vas-y vas-y voilà non il faut
attraper juste derrière la tête juste
derrière la tête parce que tout ça elle
va tourner directement
[Musique]
tout le monde doit d'y passer un premier
exercice pour tester leur sang froid
ils s'en sortent honorablement
ce ne sera pas inutile
c'est pas trop le sait pas trop
le contredit pas du tout ont l'art est
plutôt en veilleuse parce qu'en plus
avec des légionnaires
gimont assez mythique donc pour
l'instant je pense qu'on va rentrer dans
le stage c'est sûr comme ça dans les
stages commandos se met toujours sur la
réserve au début et
ça vous a fait
c'est bizarre mais voilà c'est un peu on
peut visiter comme le serpent
brèche pour tous y aller
c'est un peu d'appréhension pas si
commune
bah
il y a
on était
c'est bien de faire parler oui voilà au
plus haut ce que j'écoutais le doyenne a
fait plaisir
9h02
parti en juin
mais bon on essaye de faire le
tour des médias congolais ya aucun
format ce qui touche la terre
aux impositions
dernières séries de pompes avant le
départ aux mondiaux
c'est nul le bon ami rituel opposition
au caire avec moi
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes à 200 km de cayenne sur la
crique de la prague
c'est dans cette jungle que le
légionnaire forment les stagiaires de
sacyr les aussi les forces spéciales et
des armées étrangères
les américains ne viennent plus trop dur
didon ici
[Musique]
leur moyenne d'âge 23 ans
un élève officier sur quatre a des
parents dans l'armée
dans cette section la moitié vient de
lycée militaire le prytanée la flèche
saint cyr l'école les corniches comme on
dit à sacyr la moitié du monde civil et
ses
pieds
m
le saurions
arriver sur le bivouac après une marche
épuisante
stéphanie l'air à peine fatigué
[Musique]
d
oh
et
l'installation des hamacs monter et
démonter tous les matins
[Musique]
ensuite quoi est ce qui fait le plus
peur je pensais c'est mal à dire maladie
qu'on risque de choper
ces traîtres vous avez l'impression
d'ensemble et aux garçons votre âge
pas franchement
ça dépend ici on est on est tous au
rendez vous donc
ensemble à peu près tous et quand je
rentre chez moi voir si je suis plus je
suis plus à quoi qu'il en soit l'idée
des amis qui freinent qui font d'autres
études 1 c'est une faculté sur la brique
pilée savoir s'adapter aux aux gens avec
qui on est
brancardage sur un parcours accidenté
d'urgence en cas de conflit au loin une
autre section s'exercent au tir
la tension est forte et les deux
instructeurs pour de cet exercice une
véritable épreuve
si on pourra avancer avancer chaque
geste doit être parfaitement exécutée
avec deux autres élèves stéphanie est
volontaire pour une opération pendant
laquelle les saint cyriens se feront
pour la première fois sérieusement
malmenée par les légionnaires le prouver
m
onfray s'en remettra sans vous casser la
gueule je n'ai rien de plus à dire ciel
en fête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors fait reculer
[Musique]
oui c'est bon
pour courir ou quoi c'est quoi cette
merde
et polonais ont lancé des voulant mettre
musicale
était fleuret on y va
[Musique]
plus
c'est juste qu'à voir les genoux
attention sur les cuisses salariés
ils ont mis deux heures de plus qu'il
n'en faut pour franchir les obstacles
l'épreuve est un échec à l'aller on y va
patient ne lâchez pas comme ça allez
répondait tout
pour moi ça va c'est pour être c'était
vraiment
sale et nous ne sauverons camp mais bien
aux premières places les mots clés pour
le voyage d'affaires donc ça commence
pendant le stage
donné entrée en matière on s'attendait à
ce que ce soit aussi dure ba ba veut
dire que ceux qui dépassent les autres
années que c'était un bel élan le monde
difficile ça mais non
extradition
déjà tous les sacs ou des gars c'est la
france
les futurs chefs l'armée française ils
sont mal barrés
après on va rouler les mécaniques avec
les deux barrettes 1
les 15 minutes pour aller voir ses
armements équipements elle bloque c'est
parti je pense qu'une fille peut avoir
sa place dans l'armée mais
moi par exemple je veux choisir une arme
une arme de soutien peut-être le
matériel ou le train et je veux pas
choisir une arme de mêlée je veux pas
aller dans l'infanterie nous désarmons
facile justement parce que des activités
comme celles ci sont pas du tout adaptés
à une fille physiquement c'est
indéniable qu'on est moins forte que les
garçons ne pas faire la même chose est
ce que vous seriez prête à tuer
c'est une question difficile je pense
pas qu'on puisse y répondre comme ça
sans être en retrait devant le
fait accompli en fait
je pense que si ma vie était en danger
ou aussi celle de ma famille ou deux de
mes hommes étaient en danger je pense
que j'arriverai à tuer oui bon je le
faire pour défendre la patrie oui je
pense est ce qu'il faut c'est poseriez
une femme militaire non parce que le fai
militaire c'est plus une femme dans sa
tête
pourquoi y est ça vous pourriez demander
ça à stéphanie elle serait pas d'accord
non elles seraient pas d'accord mais
fabien dans la vie civile comment elle
se comporte ça je dirais pas
c'est pas
si c'est plus une femme puise dans sa
tête le fait qu'elle puisse
t elle puisse suivre les les mêmes trucs
que nous ramper dans la boue donner des
ordres et c'est
moi c'est plus une femme ça une femme il
doit garder toute sa féminité sa
fragilité sa douceur sa tendresse et
alors que là ça fait des gens qui sont
durs parce que évidemment tous savent
que c'est le but de tout ça c'est nous
endurcir nous endurcir moralement et une
femme n'a pas besoin est là pas besoin
de ça s'il en a besoin c'est pour faire
un métier qui serait celui de militaires
mais donc ça peut il ya incompatibilité
fais ce que je veux dire après une femme
vous voyez une femme militaire qui va
élever des enfants elle va être très dur
avec ses enfants etc elle va en faire
des vrais des vraies bêtes de guerre
c'est mon gars c'est pas possible
[Musique]
pas un moment de répit
les exercices s'enchaînent
lâchez d'hommes sur la droite
[Musique]
l'un des aspects les plus pénibles du
stage et d'être en contact permanent
avec l'eau mouillé pendant douze jours
un contraste avec les amphis surchauffe
et qu'ils connaissent toute l'année
une mise en situation qui peut servir en
cas de guerre
je suis derrière
vié
ouais
surtout l'école de la volonté et du
courage ces terrains c'est ce à quoi
c'est apprendre à s'aguerrir c'est à
dire que plus tard on sait jamais
peut-être qu'on aura un jour à conduire
des hommes ou feu et à ce moment là il
faudra quénéhen
bon évidemment tout cela c'est sa part
est hyper idéal mais dans le principe il
faut que ça reste dans cet esprit de
défense il faudra qu'ils aient des chefs
et les chefs il faudra pas qu'ils qui
qu'ils fassent défaut donc par rapport à
vis à vis de leurs hommes il faudra
qu'il soit là pour les commander bon
c'est pour ça que dans cette école nous
fait faire des stages comme ça et c'est
hyper intéressant c'est sûr parce que ça
apprend à avoir un petit peu ses limites
je pensais avant de rentrer ici qu'il y
avait davantage de
dire
de ne pas de rigueur parce que de la
rigueur y en a et de la rigueur et de la
discipline il ya de l'ordre mais je
pensais que c'était beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus renfermé en fait ces
séquences et quand même finalement un
monde d'assez ouvert et heureusement
d'ailleurs parce que l'essentiel c'est
s'ouvrir sur la nation c'est l'armé elle
était à mon service de la nation c'est
l'essentiel mais bon il est vrai qu'à
des valeurs de d'obéissance de
discipline qui sont bien plus fortes
dans le sait bien c'est ça en fait la
sueur à l'entraînement et par le sang au
combat et on se prépare éventuellement
combattre
vous avez choisi la vie militaire vaud
un certain idéal de vie et on peut
l'expliquer de la manière suivante en
fait tu
as ans d'errance des responsabilités le
goût de la vie de communauté
le désir de réaliser quelque chose
ensemble vraiment ce
vraiment un idéal de vie enfin une vie
avec un certain cachet nous dire non pas
le prestige perdu d officier prussien
mais quelque chose à vivre je pense au
haut niveau humain
et qu'à mon avis on
saisit plus difficilement ou plus
rarement dans un autre milieu
[Musique]
stéphanie aime les enfants le rock et
son petit ami à civile
elle compte bien se marier un jour ils
font dire une famille
[Musique]
mélange de féminité de volonté maths sup
et maths spé avant d'intégrer sacyr
ses parents ne sont pas militaires ils
sont fiers d'elle
allons là
ligonnet on y va il vous laisse pas
beaucoup de temps pour franchir le
dernier obstacle
là on fait des trucs et seront
difficiles en étant toujours en la boue
ça c'est grippe ça nous fait découvrir
aussi un autre milieu différent de la
bretagne ce qui compte c'est le physique
le moral
bon allez 2 foran dès le départ il faut
déjà avoir un bon physique solide jusque
pour passer l'obstacle tel que je suis
là il faut avoir un bon enfant physique
mais après il ya le moral aussi kg et
qui joue énormément fait des comptes
constamment sous la pluie y est
constamment soumis sous pression il faut
avoir un bon moral forcément vous avez
l'impression que vous vous avez vous
êtes investi d'une mission
ouais bien sûr l'émission cd première
phase
[Musique]
c'est bon tu traces du drame
m
voilà
un exemple un
parcours d'obstacles la dernière épreuve
avant la plus difficile
la survie
toujours le souci de les habituer aux
situations extrêmes
ces partitions
jéricho delà de leur dire sysmans
personnel pas celui du soldat normale
tant que futurs chefs ont
on apprend à appréhender les situations
difficiles et le commandement dans des
situations d'exception ça c'est qu'ils
règlent caractère le plus vibrant de du
stage qu'est ce qui compte le plus le
physique ou le moral à la moelle bien
sûr physique c'est rien c'est une
enveloppe
stéphanie n'abandonne pas aucune fille
des autres sections non plus
contrairement aux années précédentes où
elle n'avait pas tenu plus de quatre
jours
[Musique]
les vautours
cinq minutes pour se laver
toujours la pression
non
jusqu'au bout les élèves commencent à
être épuisé
chacun se raccroche à un idéal
je dirais pas que ce soit donc j'ai dit
dès qu'on peut avoir le patriotisme
bon bien sûr le mon pays mais c'est au
monde les nouvelles missions qu'on va
voir désormais c'est son plus fort
justement défendre le territoire en soi
mais plus pour véhiculer en fait les
valeurs de liberté qui sont pas si
l'équipe a partout dans le monde
et donc on fait dans le cadre de l'onu
dans le cadre de missions onusiennes je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de travail à
voir beaucoup de travail à ce niveau là
dans les prochaines années et
c'est ça que
ce qui m'a attiré puis bon poulain
aventure aussi parce que je pense qu'il
ya encore possibilité de vivre de belles
aventures dans l'armée
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
la survie
d'abord la simulation d'une situation
qu'ils pourront connaître plus tard
prisonniers
toutes leurs affaires sont confisquées
ou par trois aussi envie complète je
veux dire qu'on en autonomie totale
donc on n'a même pas de ficelle rayon de
se débrouiller pour monter doivent
vaquer tout pour dormir dans la forêt
quoi la section tout seul raphaël
ils sont emmenés sur un territoire
qu'ils ne connaissent pas
[Musique]
aggravant la défense
voilà
g
l'adjudant les libres à eux mêmes sans
nourriture 1 seul fusil de chasse trois
briques et pour tous une boussole pour
deux pour nous interdiction de les
accompagner
ils sont ici pour se renforcer surtout
psychologiquement ils n'ont pas
l'habitude
c'est une matière première qui est qui
et riche qui est délicate donc à quoi tu
vis dans ils sont pas mal mené ils sont
pas maltraitées comme ils le sont ici
vous avez vous suivez une pédagogie bien
précises
pour eux
pas spécialement non il faut les il faut
les pousser jusqu'à la limite là pour
essayer de les faire sortir un peu de
leurs gonds
quelquefois on y arrive
plus qu'on ne le voudrait
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui
craquent
et donc à partir de ce moment là s'il
craque comme ça en
dans une situation qui est une situation
de paix avec un scénario qui est un
scénario tout monté ben qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer s'il était en
situation de crise dans un pays en
guerre
4h kaka
hormis besoin le poisson vous avez péché
il est ou d'un manteau maintien j'ai dit
de me garder les têtes
bien sûr pas de problème on voit bien
pour le moment après trois jours de
survie
l'inspection du code ils ont
confectionné mêmes pièges et abris
moi j'ai trouvé ça tout ralenti mais
petit à petit au fur et à mesure des
heures le moindre effort de mai
monter un truc c'est pour ça que dès la
première matinée de la première journée
on essayait de faire de toutes ces
choses puisque commencé à vraiment être
faible faudrait pas nous demander de
partir à la guerre dans son élection
s'est bien passé il ya eu d'engueulade
ya eu de grosses crises et c'est tout le
monde était hyper compréhensif avec le
monde les jeunes femmes parmi vous
voulez d où vous voulez laisser se
débrouiller tout seul côté déceptions
comme tout le monde donc en led bien
évidemment on s'entraîne tous là il ya
pas de retrouver le sens on pensait
vraiment pas quelles qu aient terminé
franchement enfin là je le découvre la
vie de toute la sélection
on a un peu tous impressionnés quand
même ça c'est clair c'est peu dire que
le début liste
et on voit et vous dormir en fait on
était autour du feu parce qu'il fait pas
très chaud et la nuit on était tous
entassés autour du feu on dormait
contenus trouvés
et vous avez tenus par mahmoud ouais il
fallait bien mais c'est quand même très
dur et encore on savait on savait qu'on
allait se terminer au bout de trois
jours quoi
c'est complètement différent
et c'est véritablement survivre et son
naufrage et qui sait pas danser ce qui
va entrer on savait très bien que vous
trois jours s'est terminée et manitou
s'est montrée nue la survie pour vous
cellule null null null pourquoi c'est
nul
pourquoi c'est lui parce qu'on vous a
largué tout seul
et chef captain pas la pitié des
sections pour commander
une personne dont qu'est ce qu'on fait
on se laisse mourir
le bât blesse c'est quand même vous êtes
des futurs chefs 1 donc ok que ça
carrément un comportement comme ça
vienne de soldat de 2ème pompe la langue
d'âme parce qu'ils sont pas commandés
d'accord mais vous comme vous êtes des
futurs chefs de section là il faut vous
pour maman a indiqué le chef de section
n'est pas là on n'a pas de chef de
groupe eh ben on va se prendre en main
nous mêmes et ça n'a pas été fait ça n'a
pas été fait
c'est pas trop grave c'est pas la peine
de vous faire des noeuds au cerveau vous
avez encore un nom d'école aqua di dance
et passa plus un nom en gros en
application c'est ça
commencez à prendre votre métier là si
au bout des deux ans vous n'avez
toujours pas réussi vous êtes au même
stade que vous êtes aujourd'hui ben vous
n'aurez plus qu'à vous reposer sur votre
sous-officier adjoint et vos trois chefs
de groupe qui me connaissent leur métier
ok
je suis dr
aucun à gratter les meilleurs choisiront
les troupes de marine les paras la
légion
l'élève officier stéphanie loubersac ma
tenue
comme les autres
[Musique]